my talk the table is are changing the
game series where we highlight
extraordinary women making a difference
now in for future Generations we
continue our baseball theme this morning
ahead of MLB opening day tomorrow in
recent years women have made strides in
the sport taking on a number of high
profile roles now as Meg Oliver shows us
one college athlete is making history on
the diamonds
Watch Out Boys of Summer
[Music]
means business this was my goal
throughout High School to play
collegiate baseball regardless of the
division
19 Olivia picardo made history recently
as the first woman to make a Collegiate
division one baseball team an outfielder
for Brown University in the ivy league I
knew that I wanted to play college
baseball but I also wanted to go
somewhere that had academics that fit
the grades that I had in high school
picciardo chose brown with a plan for a
walk-on tryout she approached things
with calm Grand Achilles is the team's
head coach how many women have reached
out to you to try and try out for your
program there have been a handful a
handful since live certainly none before
she was the first yes she was the first
how would you describe her as a baseball
player so she's very meticulous with her
preparation and she's a contact hitter
that wants to put the ball on the ground
and play solid defense in the Outfield
the dusty baseball diamonds of Queens
New York have been a part of pachardo's
life as long as she can remember who
taught you how to play baseball uh it
was my dad I I kind of inherited his
love for the game and he knew that he
wanted his kids to play baseball so it
all started here in Queens all right
here and this is the path that we took
to the Little League field Olivia's dad
Max grew up playing baseball in the
Dominican Republic and was eager to
share the sport with his kids he got
Olivia on the diamond when she was only
four he still has her first fat pink and
yellow it looks so small now but uh on
the field way back there when she said
when you play when you're the littlest
she will come out to the plate and she
would slam the crap out of the bat on
the home plate Olivia became a pitcher
and outfielder and was able to hold her
own with older boys as a seventh grader
she made the high school boys varsity
team that was always the thing that I
look forward to oh practice at the end
of the day today a game at the end of
the day I'm gonna pitch today I'm so
excited
girls take to softball it was never a
consideration for picardo
I graduated high school with a sizzling
fastball
and a sparkling GPA
[Music]
and while pachado has always been a
standout she's also always found a way
to fit in just ask her Brown teammates
the first thing I was impressed by was
just how she threw the ball it's a good
sign of just what a baseball player will
be I was also impressed I hadn't really
played with any girls since little
league and I was pretty excited to see
what what she could do out here as a
freshmen Walk On Olivia wasn't
guaranteed any playing time but on March
17th with proud papa filming from the
stands
chardo became the first woman ever to
bat in a division one game it was a
ground out but it was history
what do you want other little girls out
there to know that are playing baseball
right now I guess I would tell them they
should be playing this work that they
love for as long as they want to play
[Music]
and a little more for the history books
the helmet pachardo wore during her
first at bat is now in Cooperstown where
it will be displayed at the National
Baseball Hall of Fame a museum and I
talked to Olivia last night she said It
felt great to be up at the plate but you
treated it like any other at-bat
experience very humble doesn't want the
spotlight she wants to focus on her
teammates the game but she is proud she
can play you know Nate we talk about how
you can tell in one second whether
someone's an athlete and you can see it
in her yeah the first thing you said was
that's a great swing I like the sound of
that bat when she hit the ball go Olivia
thank you Meg